there's a steep ravine debate club the
sand lob or The Mighty Ducks I thinking
I don't think one of the medium rare
ducks I know that the sandlot huh
well the Sandlot as children what is it
children I don't have a they don't know
what's going on they don't have a team
and so they get a team together well
neighborhood team and they play and then
they play against another team like best
friends and then they're the neighbor
has like a scary dog and hit the ball
over there
mm yeah let's talk about the great
Bambino oh yeah Sandlot destroys Mighty
Ducks Plus that mutt Mighty Ducks goalie
remember he's like addicted to math oh
[ __ ] man have you seen oh yeah dad
goalies a tough position man ah cues
which kids talks a bunch of rich kids
like yeah yeah wow that's a goalie yeah
I think he's stopping in some [ __ ]
meth in his veins you feel me
mm-hmm that's meth oh yeah my bean you
don't lose all that weight we gotta get
on some meth he was also in the classic
heavyweights Oh Ben Stiller mm-hmm
wonder what happened to he was such a
charming young guy you know I think grew
up in like drugs you think yeah he was
trying to meet Connor and Theo at 145 he
could use manscaped I know that I you
know not to say everybody could use it
but he could also use it that's not even
him on the right that's a different guy
but that's an alien on the right on
Weiss mugshot he was getting better
though maybe he's better now yeah he
goes getting but a little better he
still in hockey no was he back playing
hockey do we know I don't know dude he
probably he's going on he probably got
offsides in his veins dude I hope he's
yeah yeah
stuff that's icing bra is everybody cool
on the Sandlot I think so yes I want
time met squeaks and red-haired kid on
the streets of Minneapolis really they
were touring MLB stadiums and like
showing the Sandlot I gotta find this
picture that's kind of that's kind of
depressing too but still Patrick Rinna
is the redhead dudes name though the one
guide the guy who would go for ever we
used in a logic video mm-hmm 2 Chainz
what I think to change was in it wasn't
he
[Music]